[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone
thanks for joining us today 2020 was an
extremely tough year
with no end of challenges millions of
people tuned into gaming
to play create and connect with one
another
steam saw the number of concurrent users
increased by 40 percent
over the previous year and more than
double since 2018.
discord connected gamers with over 4
billion minutes of conversation
and monthly active users reaching 140
million
that's nearly three times as many as two
years ago
together we watched over a hundred
billion hours of gaming content on
youtube
that's twice as much as 2018 and with
physical sports largely on the sidelines
esports has attracted legions of new
fans
viewership is nearly half a billion
people globally
up 100 million from 2018 with another
150 million viewers expected
over the next three years more than ever
gaming has become an
integral part of our lives two years ago
we introduced a breakthrough in graphics
real-time ray tracing and ai-based dlss
we called it rtx together with microsoft
and top developers and game engines we
set off to bring the visual realism of
movies to fully interactive gaming
the momentum is unstoppable as consoles
and the rest of the ecosystem are now on
board
ray tracing is the new standard last
fall
hot out of jensen's oven we launched our
second generation rtx
the geforce rtx 30 series ampere
architecture for gamers
and our biggest generational leap ever
ampere features dedicated rt cores to
accelerate ray tracing
tensor cores for the performance
boosting dlss
and new streaming multiprocessors
together
delivering twice the performance of our
prior generation
and our ultimate play is more than just
beautiful graphics
we introduced low latency in video
reflex
so competitive gamers could be their
best and nvidia broadcast
an ai powered app that turns any room
into a home broadcast studio
over the past four months we've launched
four new ampere-powered graphics cards
from the ultimate bf gpu the geforce rtx
3090 priced at 14.99
to the 399 rtx 3060 tide
ampere has been our fastest selling
architecture ever
selling almost twice as much as our
prior generation
we know these products have been hard to
find i want to thank you for your
patience as we continue to work hard to
catch up
last ces we brought g-force gaming to
the cloud
g-force now allows gamers to play their
favorite pc games
with rt and dlss on from almost any
device
windows laptops macs chromebooks android
and ios devices
and tvs billions in total geforce now
connects you
to your favorite pc game stores like
steam
epic ubisoft and god and free to play
games
like fortnite apex and league of legends
in all over 800 pc games have been
onboarded
from 300 publishers including 80
free-to-play games
with 6 million registered users
supported by our 25 global data centers
we streamed 200 million hours of game
play in 2020
we hosted exclusive demos for the annual
game awards show
and streamed cyberpunk 2077
to gfn gamers the day of launch
rtx technology has set a whole new
standard in gaming
from amazing indie games like pumpkin
jack
to the fastest selling pc game of all
time
cyberpunk 2077 in fact
36 games are now powered by rtx
including the number one battle royale
game the number one rpg
the number one mmo and the number one
best selling game of all time
minecraft and the list continues to grow
dlss enables the great ray tracing
experience in these games by delivering
a big performance boost
with awesome image quality let's take a
look
uh
and today we are announcing more games
that support rtx
call of duty is the most successful fps
franchise
ever starting with cod modern warfare in
2019
and then black ops cold war we've worked
with activision to bring ray tracing to
the series
call of duty war zone the franchise's
free to play battle royale
has over 85 million gamers
building on our partnership with
activision warzone is adopting dlss
coming soon every rtx gamer will see a
boost in performance
and competitiveness over the years we
have worked closely with square enix
including the world famous final fantasy
and tomb raider series today we would
like to announce our latest partnership
we are bringing dlss to outriders a
brand new ip from square enix
developed by people can fly the creators
of bulletstorm
outriders is a multiplayer co-op shooter
set in an
original sci-fi universe
welcome to enoch
here if you plan on surviving you need
to rewire your brain
for aggression
the scared high and the hesitant
die you are neither
you are the aggressor you are the threat
you are outriders
five nights at freddy's the horror
themed indie hit
grew to become a massive popular
franchise
with over 30 million downloads and 30
billion youtube views
today we are announcing with developer
steel wool studios
that the latest chapter five nights at
freddy's security breach
will feature rtx ray tracing and dlss
you can expect a new level of immersion
into freddy's unique
and frightening world five nights at
freddy's security breach is coming later
this year
here's a look at game footage our
friends at steel wool put together for
us
gregory
it's getting late
let's get you home
and put you to bed
i see you
[Laughter]
this next game was developed by shanghai
thai games
one of the top china developers emerging
onto the global stage
fist forged in shadow torch is a
platformer that was inspired by classics
such as metroid and castlevania
as an action game fist features multiple
weapons
numerous combos upgradeable skills and a
classic
arcade style experience nvidia worked
closely with shanghaitai games
to bring the game to life with ray
tracing and dlss
[Music]
[Music]
esports has become the preferred sport
for tens of millions of gamers
75 of geforce gamers play competitive
games like fortnite
valorent and apex legends and 99
of esports pros are competing on g-force
so we developed nvidia reflex to help
gamers
get their best system latency from mouse
click
to display reflex has been a big hit
among
developers and gamers since the
introduction
in september a dozen games have added
support
today we are excited to announce that
rainbow six siege
and overwatch are adopting nvidia reflex
now seven of the top 10 competitive
shooters
support the technology we also wanted to
give gamers a way
to accurately measure system latency in
september
we announced four 360 hertz g-sync
esports displays that feature an
innovative tool
the reflex latency analyzer the latency
analyzer
is to an esports gamer what a heart rate
monitor is to a runner
a critical tool for measuring system
health and performance
with hardware built into the display it
measures
full click-to-display latency
today we are announcing five new g-sync
gaming monitors
from acer aoc and asus all
featuring reflex latency analyzer
these panels expand the reflex ecosystem
to include 1440p resolution and 34 inch
ultra wide the heart of the geforce
gaming platform
is our family of gpus and the 60 class
is our most popular
the affordable price point is designed
to bring the performance and features of
our latest architecture
to every gamer for example the gtx 1060
was one of our most successful gpus we
ever built
the gtx 1060 delivered a great
generational leap in performance
it could power all the latest games at
1080p
60 frames per second but new games bring
bigger worlds
and cinematic graphics that demand more
of the gpu
this is evident in the latest sequels to
these aaa games
where the gtx 1060 struggles to keep up
for instance gamers were playing
watchdogs 2 with high settings
at 60 frames per second but with
watchdogs legion released last october
they only get 24 frames per second
and an even bigger change is underway
turn on ray tracing
and these games become unplayable on the
1060.
with 90 of the installed base on gtx
now is the perfect time to deliver an
rtx for
every gamer let me introduce the new
geforce rtx 3060
which brings the power of ampere our
second generation rtx architecture
to every gamer twice the raster
performance of the 1060
and 10 times the ray tracing performance
the rtx 3060 powers the latest games
with rtx on at 60 frames per second
[Music]
[Music]
the rtx 3060 is a powerful gpu
it has 13 shader teraflops 25
rt teraflops for ray tracing and 101
tensor teraflops to power
dlss it has 12 gigabytes of g6 memory
and starts at just 329.
the rtx 3060 will be available worldwide
in late february
amazing gaming doesn't end at the
desktop
laptops are the fastest growing gaming
platform increasing
seven times in seven years there are 50
million gaming laptops
which powered over 14 billion gaming
hours last year
and the power of these laptops has
inspired gamers to find new ways to play
in console mode connected to a big
screen tv using a controller
or driving an ultra wide monitor with a
keyboard and mouse these high
performance machines
also meet the needs of 45 million
creators and everyone working and
studying from home
today we are announcing a new generation
of ampere-powered laptops
with second generation rtx and
third-generation max-q technologies
delivering twice the power efficiency of
previous generations
nowhere does efficiency matter more than
in the extremely power constrained
environment of a modern gaming laptop
so four years ago we introduced max q
max q is a system design approach that
delivers high performance
in thin and light gaming laptops it has
fundamentally changed how laptops are
built
every aspect the cpu gpu software pcb
design power delivery thermals
are optimized for power and performance
our third generation max-q technologies
use
ai and new system optimizations to make
high performance gaming laptops faster
and better than ever
traditionally gaming laptops set the
power for the cpu and gpu
yet games and creative apps are dynamic
and demands on the system change
from frame to frame today we are
introducing dynamic boost 2.0
which for the first time uses ai to
shift power between the cpu
gpu and now gpu memory
determining where it is needed most the
ai networks in dynamic boost 2.0
manage power on a per frame basis so
your laptop is constantly optimizing
for maximum performance the result is a
larger performance boost
than ever before we are also introducing
whisper mode 2.0
delivering a new level of acoustic
control for gaming laptops
whisper mode has been re-engineered from
the ground up
and is custom built into each laptop at
a system level
you pick your desired acoustics and
whisper mode 2.0
ai powered algorithms manage the cpu
gpu system temperature and fan speeds
to deliver great acoustics at the best
possible performance
next we are introducing resizable bar
which leverages the advanced
capabilities of pci express
to boost gaming performance games use
gpu memory for textures
shaders and geometry constantly updating
as the player moves through the world
today only part of the gpu's memory can
be accessed at any one time by the cpu
requiring many memory updates
with resizable bar the game can access
the entire gpu memory
allowing for multiple updates at the
same time
improving performance finally dlss is a
breakthrough for gaming laptops
it uses ai and rtx tensor cores to
deliver
up to 2x the performance in the same
power
a gpu needs to calculate almost 4
million pixels
for a single 1440p frame dlss requires
only a fraction of the pixels
which improves efficiency and increases
performance
it also delivers more battery life when
you are gaming on the go
max q has reinvented the gaming laptop
four years ago the fastest laptops in
the world were powered by a gtx 1080
averaged 40 millimeters thick and
weighed over nine pounds
after four years of innovation max q gen
3 laptops are half the size
half the weight and deliver up to 10
times of performance
more gamers are choosing to play on
laptops and with 95 percent of the
installed base
below the performance of the latest
consoles
it's time to introduce a new generation
the rtx 3060 laptop is faster than
anything on the market today including
the 2500
rtx 2080 super it's 30
faster than the playstation 5 and
delivers 90 frames per second on the
latest games
at ultra settings 1080p the rtx 3060
laptops start at just 9.99
gamers know that 1440p displays with
twice the pixels of 1080p
provide the perfect mix of high fidelity
graphics and great performance
yet they are missing on laptops for
years we've been working behind the
scenes with display manufacturers and
oems
now for the first time 1440p displays
will be widely available
introducing the geforce rtx 3070 laptop
a 1440p gaming beast it's 50
faster than the rtx 2070 and delivers 90
frames per second
with ultra settings at 1440p rtx
3070 laptops start at 12.99
finally our flagship geforce rtx 3080
laptop
with up to 16 gigabytes of g6 memory
it is a world's fastest laptop for
gamers and creators
it delivers 100 frames per second with
rtx on
and starts at 19.99
today nearly three quarters of laptop
gamers play esports
the resulting popularity of high refresh
rate laptops continues to grow
doubling this past year i'm excited to
announce that over
half of the new 30 series laptops will
offer 240 hertz or higher refresh rates
with the performance of our geforce rtx
3080 laptop gpu
gamers will be able to play at 240
frames per second
across top titles like overwatch rainbow
six
ballarat and fortnite and combined with
nvidia reflex
gamers can achieve sub 20 millisecond
system latency
enabling them to play their absolute
best
from videos to photography to 3d
animation
the creation of digital content is
exploding
nvidia studio is our accelerated
platform for creators
speeding up ray tracing and ai in over
50 applications
including adobe photoshop davinci
resolve and blender
and monthly studio drivers bring new
features
faster performance and enhanced
stability since the launch of studio in
2019 there have been over a hundred
purpose-built studio laptops and
desktops from every major oem
nvidia ampere architecture takes studio
laptops to the next level
rendering is up to five times faster
than pascal
video editors can work with ak raw
footage
use ai to simplify workflows and reduce
encode times by up to 75
artists have up to 16 gigabytes of
graphics memory to work with huge assets
across multiple apps at the same time
rtx accelerated ai will change the way
creators work for example
adobe photoshop recently introduced
neural filters
which uses ai to quickly make complex
edits to photographs
adobe premiere pro auto reframe uses ai
to convert landscape video to portrait
while keeping the action front and
center
in davinci resolve 17 the new magic mask
feature
uses ai to speed up mass creation
and tracking nvidia optics ai denoising
in blender
cleans up noise on the fly quickly
resolving 3d images
four score and seven and nvidia
omniverse audio to face
uses ai to animate unrigged 3d
characters
based solely on an audio source a new
nation
conceived in liberty and dedicated to
the proposition
that all men are created equal
today we're introducing over 70 laptops
from
every oem our biggest launch ever
these are the world's fastest laptops
that give gamers and creators
a huge variety to pick the right device
for their needs
available beginning january 26 with
prices starting at 9.99
let's take a look at what they can do
[Music]
uh
rtx is the new standard and the momentum
continues to grow
with most of the installed base
underpowered for the latest games
we're bringing rtx to every gamer with
the geforce rtx 3060.
finally as more gamers are choosing
laptops we're launching a new generation
of rtx laptops
ready to play the most demanding games
thanks everyone for tuning in today and
as always thanks to all of our fans for
all their support
and before we go we've got one more
treat for you
[Music]
[Music]
run
step
three thousand one hundred feet
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
tax away
you